Americans think our commander-in-chief
is incompetence and too slow to react as
the country continues to face Sky High
inflation soaring gas prices and a
dangerous formula shortage new numbers
spell political Armageddon for Joe Biden
69 percent say the economy is bad 65
percent say Biden is slow to react when
issues arise and over half say the man
is simply incompetent
Biden also getting slammed over the baby
formula shortage the president trying to
do a Victory lap after flying in
supplies from Europe but the formula
reportedly will not be going to store
shelves it will instead go to hospitals
doctors and other facilities President
Biden is facing all kinds of problems
but as usual the Democrats are running
cover
we're moving from the strongest economic
recovery in modern history to what can
be a period of more stable and resilient
growth President Biden has been very
decisive in his leadership beginning
with the American Rescue plan We rescued
the economy put shots in arms Money In
Pockets kids back in school laid the
foundation for robust economic recovery
you know by any metric with the
exception of inflation this country has
moved forward under his uh leadership
and some in the media claim Biden's poll
numbers are in the tank because of
negative coverage
put a little talkers always try to focus
on what does it mean if the Democrats
and Biden in the midterms forget about
that for a minute what does it mean for
our psychology for our health as a
nation and a world when you're just
inundated by seemingly negative
headlines all the time it feels like
long coveted it's like everything is bad
we can't get healthy again and really
it's a tremendous challenge I think
particularly for the media because what
stories do you focus on
okay well I think we'll focus on this
story now look Greg we've all known the
guy is not with the program we've known
it for a long time the numbers have been
clear as far as we were concerned but
now it appears that it's not just us the
voters know it the voters know it the
polling shows it you know it you know in
the beginning it's like America was like
you know let's give the guy a chance we
elected him let's give him a chance you
know we're not going to criticize him
but now it's like we're not even in two
years and they're like this guy's a
loser this guy's incompetent 57 percent
say the president is distracted 51
percent say he's incompetent 60 percent
say he's not focused we've got inflation
going through the roof and they want to
blame the media I don't know I think uh
for this country he has been an
excellent president look what he's done
he's helped arm a population so they
could defend themselves against a threat
he also showed how important a border
was and was willing to protect it and by
this country I mean Ukraine because he's
dead that's definitely not the United
States he just said that we should be
concerned about monkey pox right yeah
that's a disease spread by plug your
ears Dana I got it it's a disease spread
by Anonymous kinky sex at Raves and so
I'm just wondering are we supposed to be
concerned by this because he says I mean
we're all not like Hunter the thing is
this is an example of the president's
inability to assess the size and scope
of a problem so the criticism here is
they say that he's too slow to react
he's only too slow to react to Major
crises like crime inflation the Border
but stuff that's not important or stuff
that is external stuff that's symbolic
something that's a virtue signal he's
right on top of it I mean he I mean I
always go to the example of the Border
guard he didn't waste any time smearing
that guy oh yeah you know and and he
didn't waste any time spearing a lot of
people call like if if something suits
the woke sensibilities of the people
that pull his strings he's right there
but right now he's gone from build back
better to an absolute disaster he's like
the opposite of Babe Ruth you know what
babe would point to the bleachers and
say home run he just he does that and
then he jumps into a well there's just
no there's no logic to this all right
Dana you know when I was reading about
this
Biden was saying that he's going to
blame the Russian invasion for the food
shortage we have
well okay on the now there might be a
little bit of Merit to that as they get
closer in terms of the Ukraine and the
grain prices but what another thing
where he was quick to react and never
apologize is on the Georgia voting law
right remember he went down and he said
that Republicans are like Bull Connor he
said it was Jim Crow 2.0 now they had
increases by double digits for both
Republicans and Democrats in Georgia in
early voting and the vote actually
finally happens tomorrow he said he
wanted to run as a unifying president he
has he has unified of the country
against him 65 percent of people say
he's slow to react that's a quorum
that's that's a filibuster-proof
majority in the United States Senate now
if that's how those rules were to work
and there's this pattern that is a part
of the Biden Administration that is
extremely frustrating so the baby
formula crisis has been something I've
been really focused on I think it is a
is a terrible crisis I listened to a mom
on the radio NPR actually who was saying
that it's all she thinks about
that that's also and you think about
like back in the day when there was no
electricity or anything like a mom
that's what you had to do you were
getting that was your job like you were
making sure there was food all of this
goes back to your Basic Instincts of
like you have to make sure that you have
food and the appropriate amount for your
child but the Biden team here's the
pattern right they downplay a crisis
they either Totally Miss it or they
downplay it I think Afghanistan is a
good example inflation and certainly a
baby formula uh then what they do is
they blame somebody else okay so the
White House even went as far as to blame
Abbott for killing people yes when their
own FDA investigation said that that did
not happen and they didn't apologize for
that and Abbott then that's that CEO is
apologizing in the pages of the
Washington Post today saying that they
will do better and then after that they
search for cover and take a Victory lap
I think it is disgusting that your
taxpayer dollars went to make a hype
video about the historic airlift of baby
formula from Europe to the United States
and now and they're like wow look at all
these people are coming out it's amazing
we have this great amazing aircraft
carrier and is filled with they said 70
000 tons of baby form that no it's 70
000 pounds pounds okay that's a big
difference I'm glad that that baby
formula is here we need a heck of a lot
more of it but they did not deal with
this for seven several months and the
Secretary of Health and Human Services
Javier Becerra who again I've said is on
the witness protection program can't
find the guy anywhere he admitted that
they knew about it but then President
Biden said we could have we couldn't
have done something if we were mind
readers yeah and they won't my last
thing is the White House refuses to
answer one specific question when did
President Biden find out about the baby
formula crisis okay and here's the
problem The Whistleblower came forward
in October of last year but Sarah said
they knew about it last fall all right
and then the FDA goes in and and they
then in in the November they make the
appointment they go on in December and
then finally in February they make a
decision so the whole Administration is
is you know behind the eight ball and
slow but what's amazing one of the
points that Dana makes a Jessica and you
know I'm frustrated with the with the
baby formula for my daughter and
everybody is and I'm trying to buy it
and find it for everybody but we find
out that the person who is the CEO of
Abbott that makes the baby formula is
apologizing why is he apologizing when
both the FDA and the CDC as Dana said is
that there's no connection between the
illnesses of death and this particular
Factory is it what he had to do the
Abbott guy to get the government to
allow him to reopen his Factory
well that Bell it got passed before that
I think he's been caught up yes before
that the baby formula act in Congress
went five days ago well yeah history
that allows them to reopen not the money
that's what judges are talking about the
money
well that was just two weeks a week and
a half ago I mean everything has moved
very quickly but he's been caught up
obviously in a media Firestorm over this
and there's a lot of bad information
going around about what actually
happened did two infants die because of
the formula no that's not actually what
happened but that has fallen on Abbott's
feed and I do think honestly it's good
ceoing that he did write that piece
because there are a lot of angry parents
and people and grandparents that are
trying their hardest to find formula for
their kids so I I think it was the right
move for him he shouldn't have
necessarily been in that position but
it's exposing a big problem that the
Biden Administration is relying on
shifting to talk about and people are
saying you're just obfuscating but it is
important to acknowledge that there are
only four companies that produce 99 of
the formula that exists
well whose fault is that I'm not this
isn't uh okay but but
okay
we are bringing in formula from Europe
that is fine now because we're in a
crisis but we normally don't allow it
they actually have better ingredients in
their formula we have a monopoly of four
companies on the why are you acting
frustrated with that I said Biden didn't
do a great job because Joe Biden has
been in Washington for 40 years and he
has no idea how fragile and
uncompetitive the U.S baby formula
industry is he just wakes up to it all
of a sudden oh look what we have here we
have a shortage I was walking down the
street today I saw some skinny blonde
Mom pulling other moms aside with her
little lipo I got hypoallergenic I got
some elementum it's a black market out
there it's not funny you look at the
streets the streets are wild with these
baby formula people this is why you have
a baby formula shortage in this country
tree because the Press treats the
president like a baby right and like he
wants credit for not fixing a problem he
himself created right they're airlifting
formula from the Europeans we're getting
bailed out by the French we're supposed
to be bailing them out what's wrong with
this thing and then you look at these
numbers two-thirds of the country thinks
the economy's bad and Joe's asleep at
the wheel
when has the country agreed on anything
we are polarized on abortion climate
change the Will Smith slap but all of a
sudden two-thirds of the country agrees
we're headed off a cliff and Joe Biden's
asleep at the wheel yeah but Jessica
we gotta go he couldn't see it coming
Jesse he's not a mind reader coming up
next clean up on aisle Biden again the
White House walking back yet another
flub on the world stage
I want to Brian Kilmeade I want you to
do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now